my submission
is that what we are looking at is truly
by definition
exotic technologies beyond beyond next
generation technologies
mr president as we wrap up here are
there ufos
well i'm gonna have to check on that i
will tell you this we
now have created a military the likes of
which we've never had before in terms of
equipment the
weapons that we have and hopefully hope
to god we never have to use it
it's probably time to stop calling
people who believe in ufos
crackpots after the recent revelation
that there's actually a pentagon
task force looking into them those
materials were engineered at an
atomic level it's a capability that we
don't even possess if they can prove
that and demonstrate that
um that'll raise a lot of interesting
questions
yeah you think
and after receiving three israeli
security awards retired israeli general
and respected professor khaim ishid
is now unveiling that yes there are
aliens among us
yes israel has made contact with them
and no humanity is not ready for them
this former space official also claims
that president trump knows about the
alien
existence but was asked not to say
anything to avoid the mass hysteria
i can't speak on behalf of the
government obviously i'm not in the u.s
government anymore
my personal belief is that there is very
compelling evidence that
we may not be alone
all of these videos have been leaked in
the past but the us government now
confirms
they are genuine before you leave office
will you let us know if there's aliens i
won't talk to you about
what i know about it but it's very
interesting
[Music]
the newest branch of our military
is called the space force
you